was there a change in your thinking or
did things simply open up in Taiwan or
what happened to make in suddenly in
1988 you started making films that
looked political
Mayo number change would release his
award we are paying as you may know me
Gentiles 10 since I was ten jumping any
man or the country at our tech abating
he was jarring into cheese it is one I
like jesus oh Jesus tanganyika tatamy
santonio Theo pal de notre ami sang la
TARTA viendo 18 in fall and the whole
thing is like a nice and soon with can
be painful now way with her tongue she
liked me wats so it will have the cheese
cheese [ __ ] societal I owe me a
thought is about that neither an
attention Frank Alejo tratamento English
is tanghali matter a king is yo sheer
delight in the girl from alien fool and
down the source to the widow Congo
what's the REM qualities what's lying
one is just push out to swim yeah that's
the one a soul doesn't teach geography
not cheap register what's his article
that's opposite pay I a possessor mocad
you how Chelsea kapisa let's say call I
just yell i use the to the Charlie Kochi
decision here I get to da hora de Kamp I
the type island got only once a semester
here pirate recipient / dep entities
innocent I the e to all AT&T tournament
putting up a song fallacy oh it's on key
damn thing chillin just a common term
for that I went to cole it's how a penny
here so first part the answer as to why
I made these earlier films at the time I
was actually not very self conscious of
what was going on I was never a very
self-conscious person so a lot of these
politics stuff growing up and so on as
well all kind of happening the
background so a lot of stuff that I end
up making we were inspired by my
memories there was a direct response
night memories I particularly remember
that this instant
this is in time flee time to die at the
very end where my grandma has died has
passed away and she was just remembered
during that time she was just lying
there on the floor and we couldn't
really attend to her at the time and her
body literally just started to rot away
and her body was rocking and she
couldn't eat you couldn't do anything so
literally she was just kind of dying
there on the floor and I very vividly
remembered that a group of people came
to our house to take care of the body to
take it away and the main person
responsible for doing this I remember he
gave me a very dirty look a very harsh
look at me and to me that look signifies
it was basically saying to me you
terrible son you've disloyal terrible
child sorry not sound terrible child um
this was a very interesting memory to me
and at the time you know you can say
that these things were sad and that was
a sad time for me but for me I didn't
really associate that time with sadness
I associated with more a sense of
loneliness a sense of isolation and that
sense of loneliness isolation was in
part associated with the fact that the
coaming town the Nationalist government
moving to Taiwan so the sense of
separation isolation that's first what
inspired me to make these early films
you knew you'd are you jinny GG na ho
nicaragua condos in wauseon cancel
tonisha calendar suzhou in Farsi and
cheese what a jerk in tankers can call
me dancing go to a doctor and I so yola
to hear so when it turns the page in
such young one yeah because later on I
think it became more self-conscious as a
result of just firstly reading a lot of
books and I started to realize that the
experience of my family while my family
had gone through it was strictly linked
closely tied to the whole historical
movement at the time of the Nationalist
government moving from China to Taiwan
that in fact was the background that
characterizes the experience of my
family so I became self-conscious of the
larger political situation